NARRATOR: In 1976, a
deadly illness erupted
in a remote province of Zaire.
[music playing]
Belgian nuns tending to the
sick described horrific symptoms
followed by agonizing deaths.
REID WILSON: It attacks
tissue around the body.
It basically attacks
everything in the human body
except for your bones.
NARRATOR: Doctors from
Zaire, Europe, and America
traveled to the
epicenter to investigate.
REID WILSON: When
responders got there,
they had no idea what
they were looking at.
But they did know
that they were looking
at this deadly new virus.
NARRATOR: The
researchers might not
have known what
this new virus was,
but they learned how
it spread so quickly.
[whoosh]
Medical supplies
were so scarce here
that the Belgian
nurses had resorted
to reusing hypodermic needles.
[music playing]
This virus had an astounding
mortality rate of nearly 90%.
In less than two months,
it claimed some 300 lives.
[whoosh]
Then suddenly, the nightmare
ended, and no one knew why.
NANCY JAAX: They just knew the
virus popped out of nowhere,
and it disappeared
just as quickly.
NARRATOR: Epidemiologists
named Ebola Zaire
after the nearby Ebola river
and dreaded its return,
which it did in just a
few relatively contained
outbreaks over the next decade.
But the greatest fear was
that someday the virus
would emerge in a
densely populated
region, which it also did.
[music playing]
REID WILSON: So back in 1989,
in the Washington suburb
of Reston, all of a sudden, a
bunch of monkeys at a warehouse
started dying.
NARRATOR: Hazleton
Laboratories, Reston,
Virginia, one of the
largest animal testing
companies in the country.
A shipment of 100
long-tailed macaques
came in from the Philippines.
Two were dead on arrival.
The illness quickly spread
to dozens of monkeys.
Desperate for a
diagnosis, the company
sent samples to a high security
lab run by the military, a US
Army Medical Research Institute
of Infectious Diseases,
or USAMRID.
[whoosh]
Lieutenant Colonel Nancy
Jaax examined the tissues.
NANCY JAAX: What we found then
was really pretty alarming.
I was seeing a section of liver.
I saw all these
very large cells--
which are called macrophages--
and they were full
of material which
is very typical in a
filovirus infection.
[whoosh]
NARRATOR: A filovirus, a
tiny spaghetti-like strand
that replicates
at lightning speed
and causes devastating diseases.
Dr. Jaax was very
familiar with them.
She worked behind layers
of bomb resistant walls
where the army stored an
archive of frozen killers.
[whoosh] Marburg--
[whoosh]
--Ebola Sudan--
--and the most lethal
of all, Ebola Zaire.
Dr. Jaax used her
stash of filoviruses
to compare it to the monkey
sample, and to her surprise,
the one that matched
was the virus
that struck Zaire in 1976.
We're thinking, well,
that's not possible we
need to check it again.
And they checked it three
times, and every time,
there was no mix up.
It was showing positive
for Ebola Zaire.
JERRY JAAX: I think Nancy
came to my office and said--
NANCY JAAX: I did
go to his office.
JERRY JAAX: --you're not going
to believe what just happened.
You know, it looks like
we've got Ebola virus
in these monkeys in Virginia.
There was a lot of confusion
and going, oh, wow.
This is really crazy.
What are we going to do?
NANCY JAAX: We immediately
had to kick into high gear.
NARRATOR: The army
formed the battle plan.
The first order, euthanize the
monkeys to prevent an epidemic.
Nancy's husband, Colonel
Jerry Jaax, led the team.
JERRY JAAX: Nobody
likes killing monkeys,
but we were in an
emergency situation.
It was something that we
had to do to make sure
that we didn't have a
significant outbreak
within the human population.
NARRATOR: They dodged a bullet.
And they soon realized
this strain of Ebola
wasn't harmful to
humans, but they
knew it was only
a matter of time
before they'd have to
face the unimaginable.
NANCY JAAX: The
question, of course,
is are you going
to get a mutation
that then makes it more airborne
or makes it more contagious.
JERRY JAAX: What we did
in a contained building
was pretty dramatic, but
imagine if it was a city.
REID WILSON: The
nightmare scenario
for global public
health officials
is something that combines the
transmissibility of something
like the Spanish flu--
which infected probably about a
billion people a century ago--
and the mortality of Ebola.
NAHID BHADELIA: What
keeps me up at night
is that we'll have a disease
that's transmitted by droplets.
ANTHONY FAUCI: Something
that is respiratory-borne
that is a virus like influenza,
likely influenza, that has
both high degree of
transmissibility and high
degree of morbidity
and mortality.
REID WILSON: If something like
that spreads around the world,
we're just not
ready to fight it.
[whoosh]